[Musique]
le mt sinai center c'est l'exemple
typique d'un centre commercial au centre
ville qui est vraiment touché par la
crise de la kfw 19
le lab et qui étaient ici depuis 130 ans
vient d'annoncer qu'il ne va pas ouvrir
il ya aussi une vingtaine de locataires
qui ont cédé leur bail dans les
dernières semaines et même pour ceux qui
restent et qui ont pu rouvrir la
majorité de leur clientèle n'est pas au
rendez vous c'est vrai qu'en alberta la
situation est particulièrement difficile
avec la chute des prix du pétrole
mais ce qu'on voit ici ça nous donne
quand même un avant goût de ce qui
attend certains détaillants et
propriétaire de centres commerciaux dans
les mois à venir essentiellement les
galeries marchandes centre-ville tant
qu'on n'a pas de retour et des touristes
et des travailleurs se sent très bon ils
vont souffrir
en banlieue par contre là les clients
sont trop tôt on est rendus au west
edmonton mall qui est un immense centre
commercial en banlieue d'edmonton et là
il ya des films pour entraîner
d'ailleurs de certains magasins c'est
sûr que le west edmonton mall comme le
carrefour laval au québec où york dallas
toronto
ce sont des gros centres où il ya une
concentration de marques populaires donc
eux sont mieux équipés pour faire face à
la crise que les plus petits seins et
semblent de taille moyenne ils sont même
que plus à risque que les plus c'est à
cause la qualité des locataires ils ont
alors beaucoup d'indépendants qui
promeut penseront pas quand mais on sait
aussi que le commerce en ligne a pris de
l'ampleur dans les dernières semaines
malgré tout les clients disent encore
vouloir une expérience en magasin le
modèle qui fonctionne bien au canada
sont des deux importants on aurait vu
des joueurs qui étaient physiquement
adding ouvrir des magasins
l'expérience physique de magasinage
amène certains avantages que le
commerçant ligue 2 je pense que mes deux
complets d'après lui le centre
commercial est là pour rester la seule
chose c'est qu'il devra continuer à se
diversifier
surtout s'il est situé au centre-ville
je pense que les changements temps de
commencer à voir dans les centres
commerciaux
avec un peu plus de divertissement de
restauration
ça a porté ses fruits alors savoir
s'accélérer
au coeur des villes et centres
commerciaux pourrait aussi être tenté de
transformer certains l'heure le coo en
espaces résidentiels en hôtel ou encore
en clinique médicale ici l'heure ans
partait radio canada elle même